It has been two months since I moved in with my boyfriend,
me and my four children. We didn't move into his house.
We. You both left our leases?
Like, we both had leases that were ending at the same time
and then moved into a new place together,
him and I. And I wanted to give you a little update
because I think a lot of people were counting on my downfall
and banking on it to fail.
And, sorry to say,
womp, womp.
We have had more conflict than we're used to.
And then, since we don't have our own respective houses,
it's not like we could just go to our houses to, like,
cool off. We had to figure out how to, like,
coexist in the middle of conflict and maintain respect.
And I'm happy to fucking report this,
what we've done. We've had a couple miscommunications.
Like, there was one night where I thought he was mad at me,
but he was just sad,
and I took that as the silent treatment.
And so then I was like, well,
in fact. And so then I went to another bedroom.
I literally, like,
slept in my daughter's bedroom.
I was like, you don't wanna talk to me?
I won't be in your face. Like,
I got all fucking butt hurt.
Um.
And, you know,
the next day, we talked,
and I was like, oh,
my god, that was totally a misunderstanding on my part.
See where I Was wrong there.
Yeah, we've.
I don't know, he's done some shit that I'm like,
okay, cute.
I think it's more just like the way he is. Like,
there has been a lot of like, alright,
well, those are your kids.
I'll see you later. Where.
When he came,
when he was just my boyfriend and would just come to my house,
there was no escaping. He was my boyfriend.
Even if he was just in the like,
he never gets involved in what's going on,
but he would at least like,
kind of be hanging out with me.
So, like an adult that I could look at me like,
are you fucking hearing this?
And then that kind of disappeared.
So there was like, a little bit less support,
and that was starting to drag me a little bit crazy.
So we talked about it and he was like,
I see what you're saying. Um.
But yeah,
otherwise it's going pretty good,
pretty fun. When the kids are here,
it's like he calls them his little roomies,
and he's, you know,
building little relationships with them and,
you know, um.
Yeah, his and his relationship.
His and mine relationship,
I think took the natural hit that any relationship takes
when children are present all the time.
But I mean, I reminded him, like,
this is my availability, period,
you know? I mean,
it's not like it's. I have.
I have more availability for you now,
if anything, because you Know,
we're here together, but there's still many nights where,
you know, I go to sleep before him or whatever.
So
I don't know. It's happy.
His mom thought it was fucking hilarious
that his picture was in that people magazine online article.
Um, I thought that was adorable.
I was like, yes,
cause I really liked my makeup.
I thought it was cute. Speaking of that,
I'm doing my makeup right now.
But anyway, yeah,
life has been nice. We've settled,
we're unpacked mostly. We're like 95% unpacked.
He bought some plants for the house.
We're living it up, not living the dream.
I'm just saying we're happy.
It's fine. I don't like to, like,
hype too much shit up, you know what I mean?
There's some trauma there,
but we're doing really good, so.